[Applaudissements]
c'est lui qu'il gagne il fait du yoga
nuit avec enora celui qui perd il s'agit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors allez la saur allez c'est parti
sabine s'est pas dit mais il renvoie le
[ __ ] jouer comme ça pendant deux
heures pour que j'aimerais moi aussi
[Applaudissements]
megan et patrick si vous voulez je crois
c'est un petit point dom là l'effet des
petits points waledac un petit boulot un
stand on a jusqu'à 23h10 aller à l'état
d'épaves et c'est là qu'on en direct à
l'image il commence sa toilette comme un
dernier pas qui paierait des fois ça se
joue sur ce court ressources que plus
lointain est parti c'est la balle de
match
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
pratique patrick est tombé de la
répétition tout à l'heure oui c'est ça